eight-time russian champion peter
svidler one of the greatest commentators
in our game
and showing that it's still a player you
must feel
a bit of relief that you i finally took
one it's a nice it's a nice feeling i
think i was the last one in the field
without a win until that until today so
uh good to not be
all alone there uh
you missed that win yesterday yeah but
you weren't it was the easiest win in
the world no but you still uh to
lanier's credit he immediately like
what usually happens i'm sure you know
and the guys will will confirm
uh is normally the guy making that
blunder immediately spots it the moment
he releases the piece
and lanier told me after the game like
the first thing he said to me was wasn't
b5 winning
and uh
he had
i think less than 15 minutes at the time
and i had half an hour so i think it's
sort of inexcusable because obviously
knight of three check i was calculating
on every single move there it's not like
the idea was
alien to me but
i was so
concentrated on the idea of sort of
rescuing the rook from a7 by bringing it
back
that it just never kind of clicked for
me that on at this particular moment
it's doing very well on the seventh
so yeah that was a missed opportunity
yesterday but i was also worse out of
the opening so i mean this math never
really works
as straightforwardly as you would like
stabilize things a little bit maybe not
really no but i mean winning a game is
very nice
i mean calling minus two stabilizing is
you know such a such an indictment of
where i am you know
i wouldn't like to be stabilizing on
minus two you know if i if i were back
to 50 we could talk but this is just you
know
something to make me feel slightly less
disgusted with my play in this
tournament but no not stabilizing
you got two rounds to go
you want to be at 50
uh all out for the two wins
well i mean i'm starting i think i'm
playing black against fabi tomorrow so
you know that's not a game i
view from the start as i must win
i i don't think there's very many people
in the world who do
but
he's been playing sort of very open open
football in in this tournament so far so
we'll see i mean
opportunities could present themselves
but
i'm just mainly i'm i'm hoping to
uh to have maybe turn the corner a
little bit in terms of quality because
some of the chess i've shown before the
rest day was just abysmal
by by you know any kind of
definition so
to be playing
somewhat closer to how i would like to
play is
important and uh
today was a strange one honestly because
i
got
kind of out prepared
and
i made a practical decision on move
whatever it was 17 18 and by move 22 i
was absolutely winning which is i'm
pretty sure i'm not worse after 93 but i
should not be better
you get to that position when you play
93 and
why this result became
what it was what did he do wrong
i don't know but i suspect queen a1 is
already starting starting the the
problem obviously you can also just
ignore the opponent's e3 altogether but
i think taking on c3 and then going to
a5 yeah bishop six is definitely a move
but i i think i should be okay yeah but
i mean if black doesn't take on c3 at
least i get you know something compared
to me trying to protect the pawn on c3
where
i genuinely think i might be fighting
for equality and this is why i was kind
of unhappy with with the results of the
opening but i thought knight e3 is a
kind of a nice punt because it
you know hopefully it's not something
that
darius looked at and
i should be maintaining balance i think
and uh after quincy 395 i was kind of i
was assuming that it's possible to
meet rookie three
uh and uh that's actually a bad move
apparently yeah that's kind of funny
what what am i supposed to play and i
thought it was like strictly the best
move in the position but apparently the
machine disagrees
uh even with that which is kind of
interesting to me because i that was
like the entirety of my of my plan but
the
yeah before i thought bishop d8 and i
couldn't make it work but maybe now
ah i didn't i didn't get it yeah because
here quincy this is what i was trying to
calculate uh quincy two uh after bishop
g8 black has a 9494 on ic5
and uh
94.94 knight c5 yeah this is what i
this is what i calculated and i thought
this just doesn't work at all i think
i'm just sort of much worse here
um so oh yeah
it's kind of funny that i saw the idea
of rookie three but i played it in the
wrong order
uh it's a bit stupid honestly
um
should have actually i spent like five
seconds on this move i was so happy with
queen a1
yeah
okay i take everything back about the
quality of my play and the rest of it
yeah i just got very lucky today i
suppose um
via queen a7 is just i think a final
blunder pretty much you have to go to a8
and i couldn't really
i couldn't really see anything i was
planning to just very confidently take
on e5 and bluff because i think and once
again i look at your screen and it says
bishop d8 here if bishop d8 is actually
the best move in this position i'm very
happy obviously i can take on d6 play
[ __ ] pay 3
and pretend
uh but i couldn't actually refute knight
d595 d5 i spent like 20 minutes while
dyresh was thinking about queen a7 queen
a8 i spent like 20 minutes here trying
to find a way to to break through and i
couldn't find anything
uh because rook h3q1 this is sort of the
point
and i i spent a lot of time here trying
to figure out if rook g3 maybe is a move
or maybe i go rook h3 force between a1
and then go rg3 some kind of really
strange ideas
but
uh
yeah i couldn't quite work out what i'm
supposed to do here obviously if bishop
d8 like
but the plan was to queen a8 i just come
to the board i write down the move i go
g5 i pass the decision
to darius because i think it's a harder
decision for him because if he is if he
is wrong about quinte knight takes e5 he
gets mated
so uh in practical terms it would it
would have been a challenging uh
challenging position for him to play
um and because of that made ideas an
idea five the computer was saying knight
d4
whoa
yeah that that's not a move i considered
for a second honestly
yeah that's extremely beautiful but yeah
i can't can't give myself any any credit
here i just did not see this move
existed
but this is not something that's just
finished bishop yeah like queen d8 bit
905 bishop c8 or something i don't know
how
it actually is bishop d8 right now even
bishop yeah but like even like from a
human perspective one one of the reasons
why queen a8 is just so much stronger
than queen a7 is that you have the
option of bringing it back into the
defense with queen d8 um and uh yeah i
was going to i was going to play g5 and
uh you know say your move sir
and and see what transpires but queen a7
i mean even if i go for g5 i think it's
sort of placed worse on a7 than on a8
but bishop just kind of wins which is i
don't know exactly what he missed maybe
he missed okay three quincy two the
whole idea of just
piling on the
piling on the diagonal and the pieces
just don't escape i thought i was kind
of winning here and i think i think i am
c5 instead of c6 was slightly trickier
the one he plays g6 very quickly but
actually after c5 i think it's still
possible to go after 693 there's just no
chance whatsoever everything is so
completely tied up but c5 i think it
gets a bit weird because i think i have
to play g5 95
95
and then
uh sorry after c5 i think only five
everything gets taken off
and somewhat shockingly i don't
currently have a like i can't play queen
a1 because of queen e2 so i'm not the
queen even cleans c4 i thought and once
again i'm not sure i'm winning i'm
winning the full pc maybe i am a bishop
d3 and then bishop b3 maybe i am
no but you take on d5 no of course you
take on d5 first
you take d5 uh after let's say after
queen e1 yeah you go bishop d5 e5 queen
c4
right and uh yeah i mean
it becomes very very touch and go maybe
i'm still winning maybe i'm not i'm i'm
not at all convinced and i thought i
have a very clever move instead of all
this instead of queenie like here i
think i have queen d4 right
uh and maybe uh ah [ __ ] by five still
wins the piece yeah i'm hallucinating
completely okay fair enough uh i was
planning to make a move i thought was
kind of very aesthetically pleasing
instead of all of this i can play queen
b1 after after the exchange on e5
i can play queen b1
after which i think black has
zero moves
queen bieber
i just like the idea of you know just
making this move so that the queen
cannot go anywhere at all from a6 i'm
also preparing for bishop d5585 because
h7 will be hanging
and then let's say in this mission after
g6 i just or h6 i just want to play like
h3
and then i will play queen eight to next
move
and uh
i think i'm eventually picking picking
things up
but yeah i've
that would still have required some work
after c6 93 you can more or less resign
because
there's not even any counter play your
pieces are just completely completely
stuck and left the queen b5 i think i
have probably like
10 different ways of winning this piece
this is just the simplest
of your queen bee one as the absolute
best move
nice
so you are still a player sir
nice well congratulations on your
victory today thank you and let's hope
uh
at least for the russian fans and your
other many fans that you continue to
play well i know there are a lot of
american fans thinking oh don't beat
bobby though
nice thank you peter you're you're such
a great commentator and it's so
wonderful to have you here uh
please let me
take a moment and exploit your presence
sure and to bring your game to
bring your attention to the game between
shaq and fabi tell me what's going on
can i can i start by asking you a
question please have you guys worked out
why starting with bishop g6 is more
precise than starting with luke e8 no we
have not
[Laughter]
and i have no idea yeah i i i saw fabie
play bishop g6 because by that point
c693 was already on my board i could
actually you know today i actually was
sort of justified looking at other
boards by this point okay and i thought
yeah i have no idea why you would not
just play rook a8 and move i think in
the no i think after queen just uh
next move i think even here it's very
logical very having played queen g7 rook
f1
why would you not play rookie 8 there
uh i i don't know i i'd be extremely
interested to hear fabi's fabi's
thoughts on this
and the entire game is unbelievably
interesting to watch yeah and just this
exact uh moment i know we've got wesley
uh waiting in the wings anxiously to
jump in uh your
knee-jerk uh thoughts like would you
rather unfortunately i glanced at the
maurice's screen so
my thoughts are now polluted but uh it
feels like black should like i i
understand the machine says black has
something i don't know what that
something is though uh maybe knight g2
no but 92 should lose somehow maybe does
it right maybe two works but why should
is this i thought bishop g6 was winning
but you can take on f1 and then on the
f4 on g6
uh so maybe that's it because obviously
like if you give white one more temper
to stabilize somehow rook f3 or
something the game will just finish
so maybe this works somehow
and then you get all kinds of like
strange positions like windy to bishop
d3 i guess rook f3 we can maybe even go
rookie two there
wow and go for rook ending where our
rooks are so active that the fact that
we're two down is maybe not that
relevant to that queen d3 we take on d3
we take on f4 and the entire queen side
is hanging
take on d3 and d3
well seems very playable for black at
least yeah i mean we are we are two down
but yeah i don't know rook f2 and then
rook takes a2 i don't think black loses
very many of these
that's why we love you as a commentator
uh peter thank you so much we just do
have to get wesley in here because it's
so nice of the players to come down
congratulations again thank you well
done getting